is that school teacher Yusuf manasra
says he's fed up he came all the way
from Southern Hebron to Ramallah in the
occupied West Bank demanding better pay
every year we protest we need the
government to abide by the previous
agreements
[Music]
are not beggar
and I Rely just on my salary I wouldn't
be able to provide for my family I give
private lessons on the side I am forced
to now in its fourth week the teacher
strike has left 1 million students out
of school
it began as a call for higher pay but
now many are also protesting against
their own Union which they say is siding
with the government
the teachers union is politicized
there's no democracy we don't vote for
our Representatives the government
handpicks them we don't know their
programs we don't need a fake union we
need one that defends us teachers manage
to get to Ramallah from different cities
in spite of the checkpoints put up by
the Palestinian Authority's Security
Forces to limit the number of
participants the Prime Minister says
that the government is in a deep
financial crisis and can't meet all
demands
on their salary to be paid later in good
faith we offer to refrain from deducting
salaries of protesters and to protect
the educational process what's going on
is dangerous for our children and their
future
it's not only teachers the engineers and
lawyers Union have also been striking
the Palestinian Authority has been
paying its employees only 80 percent of
their salaries for over a year the
political system is deteriorating senior
officers are fighting over benefits and
people say there is no social justice
there is a crisis of trust in the
Palestinian Authority during previous
years International Aid has helped the
Palestinian Authority deal with such
protests now that the aid is declining
the PA is finding it difficult to
fulfill its commitments Ibrahim
al-jazeera the occupied West Bank